are we in an acute housing downturn
right now it's july uh end of july 2020
when we're taping this will come out in
august 2020.
not yet i think what we're seeing is
almost the opposite it it's defined
gravity a little bit jason
it's a little bit like the stock market
which today seems a little bit
disconnected
to the real economy what you're seeing
in housing
is for the most part especially if you
get out of the urban
areas in the high end prices have have
really
um held up quite well you're still
seeing price increases
very low inventory um and so that
shortage of supply and the low interest
rates are really contributing to i think
still a
more of a bull housing market you know
more like three and a half four months
of supply
not six which might be more of an
equilibrium so um
so i would say uh we're gonna have to
wait and see how things
transpire over the next 6 to 12 months
because i think there are some
offsetting effects that that will be
at play and we'll see which dominate so
there are a number of factors it's
multi-variable here
one is interest rates are historic lows
that is a massive contributor correct
absolutely and it's is that sustainable
these historic lows
was it three percent was the average
mortgage uh in the last month or two
yeah you're seeing some sub three
percent um
so really pretty much historic lows uh
what's interesting is i think it is
sustainable
in particular because that is something
that's largely uh
in the control something it's policy
that's largely dictated
by the fed um if indeed you see so much
global weakness and uncertainty
i think we're in an era of cheap money
for a while
and it's one of the things that i i
don't expect
um to go up meaningfully anytime soon
there are very few things that i feel
that certain about
yeah if we're printing trillions of
dollars and
giving unemployment to the level no
judgments here but we're giving
unemployment to the level that some
people are making 150 or 200 of their
salary
the idea that people who want a mortgage
can get a low rate is pretty easy
table stakes and then you also have this
pent-up demand because people weren't
able to see houses for three or four
months
so certainly that's contributing right
yeah absolutely i think also
being trapped at home is making people
over index almost on the importance of
where they're
so in fact we'll talk about our business
a little bit but
we we traffic in rental housing right
and so we're at
record occupancies record leasing people
don't want to move
and i think it's the same thing people
moving out of cities buying homes where
there's more space
and people buying bigger houses because
now they're looking at perhaps a work
from home
environment for the medium term maybe
long term and so people are are trading
up and buying
more more space so to confirm
and we'll get we'll get to roof stock in
a moment i just want to set the stage
here
in the housing market you have people
who
are looking at interest rates that are
an all-time low
you have a little pent-up demand because
people haven't been able to view homes
for three or four months when they're
shelter-in-place orders and that's being
lifted
and then you add to that people are
anticipating
some percentage of people that they're
going to be staying at home
uh and working from home on some
permanent or semi-permanent basis which
means
a family that needed a three or four
bedroom might need a four or five or six
bedroom or an adu or converting the
garage into an office whatever it takes
and then you add to this flight out of
cities
because people believe uh
that because of work from home they can
have a better lifestyle they don't need
to be at the office that's one and
number two maybe cities are a little bit
dangerous because pandemics will spread
in them quicker so you put all this
together it's creating
movement and in real estate movement
is good for business correct yeah it
creates transactions
so uh absolutely yeah i think all of
those are important factors
and i don't see any of them changing
dramatically in the
in the near term